you are a man oh thank you buddy
that's a cowboy right there hello today
we're gonna talk about Dolly Parton and
Porter Wagoner Porter Wagoner had his
own television show in Nashville on his
show he sang songs and he also had what
they called a girl singer named Norma
Jean but Norma Jean left the show enter
Dolly Parton and Dolly Parton just
thinks oh she heard the songs that I
sent in for Norma Jean and wants me to
write more songs and Porter Wagoner sits
her down and is like hey I want you to
be on my showing you'll be the girl
singer because you're a girl over then
of course the next six years just like
kill it
thirteen two albums 18 hits and everyone
loves them and she wants to have a solo
career but every time she writes a song
and he's like you got to do it this way
I'm the boss it's my be show you will do
it how I say I'm Porter and it's the
Porter Wagoner show you're my girl
singer okay I guess I'll follow along
because I have to because you're the
boss but her so look like none of her
songs are doing that well in her solo
career and one night she signs an
autograph with this little Auburn haired
girl she says hey darlin what's your
name and the girl says Jolie and she
says jolene jolene jolene jolene that is
the name of a country and western song
and that is her first huge hit everyone
is like we liked that song
Dolly Parton so they clapped but they
bought the record and now she's got a
tell Porter Wagner and she's got to go
and do her own thing
and she doesn't know how to tell him so
she decides I got to write a song
because that's how when you're Dolly
Parton that's how you express yourself
she sits him down and she sings to him I
will always love you
I will always love you fact it's
probably the most beautiful songs ever
written and if you if you listen to that
song the course that song she makes this
promise to Porter Wagoner I will always
love you
he says that is the most beautiful thing
I've ever heard in my life
that's the best song you've ever written
of course you can go I'm gonna literally
Instagram this right now where's my
phone she goes to New York City and she
walked straight into the RCA offices yes
me Dolly Parton here's what's about to
happen
I'm leaving the Porter Wagoner show I'm
getting brand-new producers I will be
bridging country music and pop i'ma be
in movies are you in or are you out
back me or back off and they're all like
cool we're in yeah absolutely
we're in yeah you're yeah in Dolly
Parton yeah hey let's do and she does
exactly what she said she do those RC
executives she starts recording pop
music and Porter Wagoner Porter Wagoner
only thought about himself Porter
Wagoner Sue's Dolly Parton basically
says I want 15% of what you did I want
15% of what you're doing and I want 15%
of what you're gonna do and Dolly Parton
is like Porter Wagner just chill chill
out man
so she's like let's settle out of court
the record was like cool I'll take the
million dollars I like a million dollars
what does she do next only makes her
first movie Dolly Parton is making 95
she's making best lavoris in Texas she's
crushing it Porter Wagoner during this
time he's off blowing money he's giving
jewelry out to the women like crazy he
buys
in Orange Grove he owes the IRS $500,000
but Dolly Parton made a promise to
Porter Wagoner she would always love him
and she did and buys his entire music
catalog from him for millions of dollars
she helped him out when he was destitute
finally when he gets back on his feet
Porter Wagoner tries to buy his music
catalog back from Dolly and she sends
him a fax and the fax just says you can
have it all back for free love you dolly
oh boy I am real drunk in 2007 Dolly
Parton has a premonition that she needs
to go to Porter Wagoner Porter Wagner
was dying she went to his deathbed she
sang to him but no I think of you each
step
we're always low
oh and she lived up to that promise
until his and I'm sure to her dying day
I really wanted to sing did I ever sing
oh boy did you sing today really well
why did you sing did
you